Emotions boiling over in
a Florida courtroom
just ahead of the sentencing
of the gunman
who killed 17 people
at the Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School.
CNN's Carlos
Suarez has been covering this tr
since the very beginning.
Carlos,
today was not about
changing the gunman sentence.
It was about the victims familie
getting a chance to address them
Tell us about what they said in
That's exactly right.
Right, Wolf.
There was a great deal of anger
here, understandably so.
Much of that anger
was directed at Nikolas Cruz.
But some of it was set aside
for the jury
as well as Nicholas
Cruz's defense attorneys.
The Parkland school gunman
will be sentenced
tomorrow to life in prison,
but he must first hear from surv
and the families of those
he killed in 2018.
You took away an angel that day.
That could have made
a difference in society.
You sold him from us
and you did not receive
the justice that you deserved.
He gets daily meals
a roof over his head
and a bed to sleep in.
Though
my sister's roof is six feet of
and her bed is a coffin.
Many of the families were outrag
by a Florida jury's decision las
not to recommend that Nikolas
Cruz be sentenced to death
for killing 17 people
at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High
Three jurors
voted against a death sentence,
which in Florida must be unanimo
The defense had argued
Cruz was mentally ill
and should be spared at death.
I feel betrayed by our justice s
The murderer is not a victim of
during pregnancy.
He is not a victim of mental
health issues.
He is a murdering bastard.
That should be made an example
by being sentenced to death.
If this the worst mass
shooting to go to trial
does not deserve the death penal
what does?
In deploring his sentence,
many spoke directly to Cruz
You don't know me,
but you tried to kill me.
Parkland murderer.
I hope your maker sends
you directly to hell
to burn to the rest of your eter
Things got tense
when Cruz's lead attorney asked
to stop Victims' families
from attacking the defense team.
Their families and jurors.
I did my job in.
Every member of this team
did their job to us,
and you should not
personally be attached to that,
nor should our children.
But the state argued
the defense cannot limit
what the families and survivors
These victims have every right
to express themselves.
After a brief recess,
the defense team again
brought up the verbal attacks,
even making a reference
to the judge's children.
I can assure you
that if they were talking about
your children,
you would definitely those
you need to sit down right now.
You're out of line
In fact, you're excused
Nikolas Cruz showed no emotion i
He stared at every single speake
and showed, again, zero emotion.
In all of this.
His attorneys,
they do not expect him to say an
Tomorrow
when we hear from more of the vi
And then the judge will sentence
to life in prison without parole
Carlos, did
the judge address the families
No, the judge
did not take any actions
against the family,
the defense attorneys.
They, again,
tried to raise their objections
to some of the comments that wer
some of the family members.
The judge, however, was not havi
She said that they had every rig
to be there and say whatever the
And at one point,
she asked one of Nicholas
Cruz's attorneys
to go ahead and leave the courtr